[Música]
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y aquí iniciamos un especial
informativo de france 24 hoy con las
posesiones del nuevo presidente de perú
pedro castillo el profesor o rural el
líder sindical e izquierdista del
partido perú libre asume la presidencia
hasta el año 2026 estamos viendo las
imágenes en directo desde el congreso de
lima su llegada a la casa de pizarro no
es fácil su candidatura comenzó siendo
casi invisible y tras dos vueltas
electorales sólo obtuvo la victoria
contra la derechista keiko fujimori por
poco menos de 45 mil votos ahora recibe
un territorio devastado por la pandemia
y se enfrenta a un congreso de mayoría
opositora sobre los desafíos del nuevo
mandatario vamos a conversar con nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
y también con nuestro analista e
invitado de hoy en su era el estudio de
la encuestadora y más solo y veedor
internacionales de las elecciones en
méxico gracias a ambos por estar con
nosotros y comienzo a conversando con
nuestro corresponsable francisco
zacarías mientras esperamos
discurso en el congreso francisco
precisamente mucho hermetismo se ha
visto en torno a los temas que tratará
el líder en su primera intervención ante
el país como presidente que se sabe de
lo que dirá pedro castillo en solo
minutos
bueno se espera ante todo que
a conocer cuando hacer su proyecto de
reforma de la constitución pero casi va
en la campaña electoral prometió que va
a convocar una asamblea constituyente
para modificar la carta magna de este
país que fue aprobada en 1993 durante el
gobierno del ex presidente alberto
fujimori otra de las dos anuncios antes
de asumir el poder ha sido que él va a
renunciar a su sueldo de presidente de
los peruanos y solamente va a recibir el
sueldo que le asigna el magisterio por
ser profesor de una escuela rural y
también ha dicho que va a plantear al
congreso de este país tanto los
ministros como los legisladores ganen el
sueldo a la mitad de lo que recibían
antes justamente ya han habido algunas
reacciones de diversos sectores de los
partidos políticos que dicen que ellos
van a rechazar cualquier proyecto de
modificación de la carta magna y esto
también va a poner en tela de juicio la
relación que va a tener el pedro
castillo con el nuevo congreso de perú
pedro castillo al igual que sus
antecesores
pedro pablo kuczynski y martín vizcarra
va a tener que enfrentar un congreso de
mayoría opositora precisamente en una
coalición de partidos de derecha está
teniendo la mayoría en este congreso de
130 de legisladores y va a ser la
gestión de tender puentes para anotarle
establecer algunas alianzas con los
organizadores de las otras bancadas
para tratar de sacar adelante sus
proyectos que él trate de emprender
justamente acá vamos a recibir la
información de que la juramentación de
su gabinete ministerial que estaba
programada para esta tarde a las 4 y ha
sido postergada para el día de mañana
que en la ciudad de ayacucho va a
juramentar el primer ministro de su
gabinete y los demás integrantes harán
lo propio el día viernes en esos
momentos pedro castillo quien está
vistiendo o mejor dicho portando un
tradicional sombrero de su región en
cajamarca
dispuesto a dirigirse a peruanos el
acaba de juramentar por los pobres del
país y ha dicho que va ante todo cumplir
con su promesa de efectuar una nueva
constitución al país tal como lo ofreció
y esto es lo que han estado conversando
todos estos días los diversos voceros de
los partidos políticos también como
integrantes de las empresas tienen con
mucho recelo sobre los cambios que puede
ejecutar pedro castillo él también en
campaña prometió que va a nacionalizar
las empresas que se dedican a la
explotación de los recursos naturales en
lo que se refiere a la minería energía y
también petróleo esta situación está en
estos momentos
en un país dividido que es el que asume
el pedro castillo y va a tener que hilar
muy fino en lo que se refiere a su
gobierno las relaciones con el congreso
de perú van a hacer de todo tensas tal
como lo señalan diversos analistas
políticos porque la gran mayoría de
simpatizantes de los grupos de derecha
que son muy allegados a keiko fujimori
menor o mejor dicho no avalan su
nombramiento de presidente y tampoco los
planes políticos y las estrategias de
gobierno que él pretenda aplicar durante
su gestión va a ser la primera prueba de
fuego el mensaje al país y cuál va a ser
la reacción que puedan tomar los
peruanos ante esta situación sobre todo
en un 50 por ciento de la población que
quiere cambio cambio en el sistema
político y económico
gobernando este país por más de 30 años
ellos son los peruanos de condición
humilde trabajadores indígenas
campesinos y también solo tengo gente
que está pidiendo que cumpla sus
promesas
gracias francisco vamos a escuchar al
nuevo presidente que ofrecerá
precisamente en segundo su primer
discurso ante la nación
[Aplausos]
señora presidenta del congreso en la
república
señores y señoras congresistas de la
señores presidentes de las hermanas
repúblicas de argentina
bolivia chile ecuador su alteza el rey
de españa
señores vicepresidentes señores
cancilleres
señores miembros del honorable cuerpo
diplomático
autoridades presentes
mujeres y hombres de mi amado
pueblo peruano
comienzo saludando a mis hermanos o
descendientes de los pueblos originarios
a mis hermanos ronderos
a mis hermanos maestros a mis hermanos
quechuas
a los aymaras
a los awajún a los hermanos si vivos a
los con hijos a los hermanos apro
peruanos
me dijo usted es este símbolo día en que
se cumplen 200 años de la declaratoria
de la independencia del perú dos siglos
de vida republicana
es un inmenso orgullo para mí estar en
este recinto
pero a pesar
[Aplausos]
de que conmemoramos una fecha tan
simbólica nuestra historia en este
territorio viene de mucho más atrás
somos una cuna desde hace 5.000 años de
civilizaciones y culturas
trascendentales en nuestras tierras
florecieron importantes y extensos
estados como el war iii y luego el
tahuantinsuyo
durante cuatro milenios y medio nuestros
antepasados se encontraron maneras de
resolver los problemas y de convivir en
armonía con la rica naturaleza que la
providencia nos ofrecía
fue así hasta que llegaron
los hombres de castilla
que con la ayuda de múltiples filipinos
y aprovechando un momento de caos y
desunión lograron conquistar al estado
que hasta ese momento dominaba gran
parte de los andes centrales
la derrota del incanato dio inicio a la
era colonial fue entonces y con la
fundación del virreinato que se
establecieron las castas y diferencias
que hasta hoy persisten
los tres siglos en los que este
territorio perteneció a la corona
española le permitieron explotar los
minerales que sostuvieron el desarrollo
de europa en gran parte con la mano de
obra de los abuelos de muchos de
nosotros
la represión a la justa revuelta de
tupac amaru y micaela bastidas terminó
de consolidar el régimen racial impuesto
por el virreinato acabó con las élites
andinas y subordinó aún más a la mayoría
de los habitantes indígenas en este rico
país
40 años después la independencia del
virreinato del perú de españa en 1821 no
trajo consigo una mejora real para la
mayoría de los peruanos los denominados
aborígenes continuaron siendo explotados
como ciudadanos de segunda categoría
para el erario de la flamante república
del perú
con el tiempo a la antigua comunidad
afroperuana atraída a la fuerza
se agregó la proveniente de china y
luego del japón
sangre que enriqueció nuestras venas
pero lleva también consigo el dolor
estas no son historias de un pasado
remoto hasta muy avanzado el siglo 20
quienes eran señalados como indios según
aportando al estado una contribución en
trabajo conocida como conscripción vial
mientras en la amazonía muchos pueblos
se lavan voluntariamente ante el avance
feroz de los caucheros que impusieron
regímenes de esclavitud y violencia
los que fueron ampliamente registrados
en el famoso informe inglés llamado el
libro azul hasta los pasados años 60
muchas haciendas se vendían con
campesinos adentro
incontables peruanos seguíamos viviendo
en el servidumbre
recién con la constitución del 79 todos
los adultos pudimos ejercer el derecho
al voto
la organización popular logra avances en
el acceso a los derechos proceso que se
vio truncado por el golpe de estado de
que sentó las bases para un recorte de
derechos un debilitamiento del estado y
para las reglas que rigen hasta hoy
desde entonces nuestro país ha crecido
en diversos gobiernos
accedieron al poder gracias al voto
popular que sin embargo los han
defraudado esta vez un gobierno del
pueblo ha llegado para gobernar con el
pueblo y para el pueblo
[Aplausos]
para construir desde abajo en la primera
vez que nuestro país será gobernado por
un campesino una persona que pertenece
como muchos de los peruanos a los
sectores oprimidos por tantos siglos
también es la primera vez que un partido
político formado en el interior del país
gana las elecciones democráticamente
[Aplausos]
de un maestro más precisamente un
maestro rural es elegido para ser
presidente constitucional de la
república es difícil expresar el
altísimo honor que significa para mí en
este momento
quiero que sepan que el orgullo y el
dolor del perú profundo corre por mis
venas
que yo también soy hijo de este país
fundado sobre el sudor de misa de mis
antepasados
erguido sobre la falta de oportunidad de
mis padres y que a pesar de de eso yo
también lo vi lo vi resistir que mi vida
se hizo en el frío de las madrugadas en
el campo y que fueron también estas
manos del campo las que cargaron y me
hicieron a mis hijos cuando eran
pequeños que la historia de este perú
tanto tiempo silenciado es también mi
historia
que yo fui ese niño de que estudió
en la escuela rural 10 465 de puño que
hoy estoy aquí
para que esta historia no sea más la
excepción quiero que sepan que tienen mi
palabra
no los defraudaremos no los defraudaré
[Aplausos]
nuestras líneas políticas
la lucha contra la pandemia del del cob
y 19 preservar la salud y la vida
nuestra primera gran tarea es continuar
la lucha contra la pandemia del club y
19 que tanto ha golpeado a nuestro país
en esta fecha no quiero dejar de
recordar a tantos y a todos los peruanos
y peruanas que ya no están con nosotros
y a quienes hoy los extrañan y los
extrañamos honraremos su memoria
asegurando que esto sea una prioridad
las mutaciones del virus aún sorprenden
a los científicos del mundo esto no ha
terminado pero estoy absolutamente
seguro que saldremos adelante
construir construyendo sobre lo avanzado
escuchando a la ciencia y poniendo el
bienestar de los peruanos por delante
nos toca gobernar en un momento de
enorme gravedad para el perú
pero debemos maximizar nuestro esfuerzo
para alcanzar la vacunación de toda
nuestra población en el menor tiempo
posible
[Aplausos]
la salud en nuestro gobierno será un
derecho fundamental un derecho
fundamental que el estado debe
garantizar la salud física y mental será
primera prioridad en el gobierno
concretaremos un sistema de salud
universal unificado gratuito
descentralizado y participativo se
priorizará la atención médica primaria
para fortalecer la prevención y acercar
la salud a la población mejoraremos la
capacidad de atención de centros y
postas de salud e impulsaremos la la
conformación de cinco mil equipos de
atención comunitaria integral que
tendrán un criterio territorial para que
ninguna familia peruana
sin cobertura médica debemos fortalecer
la atención hospitalaria al término de
mi mandato entregaré hospitales
especializados por región entre los
cuales priorizaremos hospitales materno
infantil hospital neoclásico hospital
clínico-quirúrgico hospital de medicina
tropical y hospital de salud bucal
[Aplausos]
para poder llevar la salud a todos los
peruanos tenemos que través trabajar
articuladamente entre todos los niveles
del gobierno cada uno desde su función
por eso invoco a los gobernadores
regionales del país a elaborar sus
expedientes y ubicar los terrenos donde
se construirán estos hospitales
[Aplausos]
iniciaremos además con la construcción
del hospital en san juan de lurigancho y
en el vrae
debemos
[Aplausos]
debemos terminar con el centralismo que
provoca que millones de peruanos tengan
que viajar a lima por una consulta
médica necesitamos además además valorar
el trabajo de los hombres y mujeres que
han dedicado su vida a la salud
quien no se conmovió durante este último
año con su esfuerzo y sacrificio cientos
han fallecido durante la pandemia y a
ellos también nos debemos a quienes se
desarrollaron en el campo de la salud
quiero que sepan que tienen en este
gobierno a un aliado
no más trabajos precarios el país
necesita mantener el compromiso y aporte
de los trabajadores y los colegios
profesionales de salud desarrollaremos
las capacidades en el país y que el país
necesita y descentralizar hemos los
recursos humanos del sector y a todos
los peruanos y peruanas les digo que su
salud y bienestar es nuestra prioridad
[Aplausos]
reactivación económica
en los últimos 30 años se ha discutido
mucho sobre las falencias del modelo
económico implementado en los 90 a pesar
de ello ningún gobierno escucho el
malestar de las mayorías y así se
rehusaron a realizar los cambios
anhelados por la población pero la
pandemia terminó por visibilizar que las
críticas que se les hacía el modelo
económico no sólo eran legítimas eran
también válidas hoy la población pide
cambios y no está dispuesta a renunciar
a ellos ahora
[Aplausos]
ahora bien
es cierto que esos cambios se implican
poner en riesgo los logros conseguidos
con el esfuerzo de todos los peruanos
durante las últimas décadas no
no lo es
si es posible realizar estos cambios con
responsabilidad respetando la propiedad
privada pero también poniendo por
delante los intereses de la nación y
nada
hacia eso apuntamos porque queremos
construir un país más próspero más justo
un país donde una mayor generación de
riqueza y bienestar se distribuya de
manera equitativa entre todos los
peruanos
[Aplausos]
este es el compromiso que hoy 28 de
julio en este bicentenario
asumo asume nuestro gobierno hoy nos
urge la recuperación de los empleos e
ingresos de las familias lo que exige
una reactivación de la economía a fondo
lamentablemente durante la campaña
electoral se ha tratado de asustar a la
población con el cuento que queríamos
expropiar los ahorros las casas los
automóviles las fábricas y otros bienes
de propiedad de los ciudadanos lo que es
totalmente falso
[Aplausos]
no haremos nada de eso porque queremos
que la economía mantenga orden y
predictibilidad que es la base de las
decisiones de inversión la propiedad de
las personas obtenidas con esfuerzo y en
el marco de la legalidad está
garantizada por el estado
lo que nosotros proponemos es que se
acaben los abusos de los monopolios de
los consorcios que corrompen y cobran
sumas artificialmente elevadas por los
bienes y servicios básicos como ha
sucedido con el gas doméstico y las
medicinas
[Aplausos]
y cuando las entidades financieras
cobran hasta el 200% por crédito de
consumo así por ejemplo el banco de la
nación deberá estar en caen en capacidad
de proporcionar al ciudadano todos los
servicios bancarios disponibles con
tasas de utilidad razonables que les
permitan competir en este mercado con
eficacia
pero sin usura no pretendemos ni
remotamente estatizar ninguna economía
ni hacer una política de control de
cambios sólo queremos que la economía de
las familias sobre todo la de menores
ingresos sean más estables y prósperos
que las grandes empresas no está hacen
al fisco inmediato la evasión o elusión
tributaria que el estado cumpla su
función supervisora y defensora del
ambiente del consumidor y de la sociedad
no creo que ningún verdadero peruano
pueda estar en contra de este propósito
[Aplausos]
el caso de la baja con es un baldón que
nos perseguirá por mucho tiempo tenemos
que desterrar la corrupción pero para
eso tenemos que sancionar con dureza y
firmeza a todos los que participen en
ella en el caso mencionado vemos a
muchos funcionarios incluso hasta tres
ex presidentes del país implicados dos
de ellos han sido detenidos pero
paradójicamente no vemos preso a ningún
empresario algunos lo estuvieron unos
días pero ahora ya están libres y hasta
fuera del país esto no es correcto
[Aplausos]
la promoción de la inversión y una nueva
forma de hacer proyectos en el perú en
el perú es un país de milenaria
tradición minera y agrícola todas las
culturas que florecieron en el
territorio nos han dejado muestras de su
habilidad que hoy es parte del
patrimonio de todos nosotros sin embargo
hoy se tiene una anomia crítica en el
sector de minería energía e
hidrocarburos implementaremos el
criterio de rentabilidad social que es
superior a las licencias a la licencia
social esto significa que todo proyecto
debe contribuir entre otros con
dinamizar la economía local regional y
nacional
e incrementar realmente el ingreso
nacional propiciando el ingreso neto de
capitales y que los beneficios se
contabilicen localmente
donde la recaudación de impuestos o
regalías sea positiva y relevante
mejorar el nivel de empleo y salarios
condiciones y salarios de acuerdo a lo
que señala la organización internacional
del trabajo realizar transferencias
tecnológicas la inversión foránea
extranjera o extra regional es un medio
para difundir tecnología en las áreas
receptoras mejorar la distribución del
ingreso donde la intervención no genere
grupo grupos privilegiados y otros
excluidos promover
y preservar la cultura y el medio
ambiente toda intervención debe
cuantificar certeramente el cierre de
minas y otorgar garantías reales sobre
cualquier pasivo ambiental los actores
deben acondicionarse a cada escenario y
no al revés los pueblos y las
organizaciones territoriales deben
participar activamente en la gestión de
su desarrollo si un proyecto no tiene
rentabilidad social simplemente no va
[Aplausos]
esto significa un nuevo pacto con los
inversores privados donde el estado
intervenga para reducir costos facilitar
procesos mantener la seguridad jurídica
y a cambio
la población local y el país reciban
contribuciones que generen desarrollo y
mayores oportunidades con un real
cuidado del medio ambiente se promoverá
la participación del estado como la
hacen todos los países de la región como
socio o ejecutor mayoritario el estado
peruano enfrenta difíciles retos a corto
y mediano plazo
necesita una nueva forma de hacer
minería
en su rol
en su territorio
en su bien en un escenario de paz con
justicia social donde cada pueblo sea
protagonista de su destino principales
acciones a desarrollar en mi gestión
desarrollaremos lo siguiente en salud
frente a una tercera ola de contagios
tenemos a la fecha 16 por ciento de la
población vacunada
con dos dosis y un primer nivel de
atención muy débil muy débil esto
significa el enorme desafío de llegar a
fin de año al más del 70 por ciento de
la población vacunada y lograr la
protección comunitaria vamos a
comprometer todo el aparato del estado
y con nuestro pueblo movilizado en tal
sentido convocaremos de inmediato a todo
lo gobernador regional a los y a sus
directores regionales a evaluar acciones
ante la pandemia los centros y puestos
de salud garantizarán la atención médica
laboratorio y exámenes con real gran
gratuidad
y no
asegurados si dispondrán las medidas
para ampliar los horarios de atención
para pacientes no kobe hasta 12 horas en
los establecimientos del ministerio de
salud y la seguridad social
se tomarán las medidas necesarias para
continuar con la vacunación ampliando
horarios y extendiendo su presencia en
las zonas más populosas de las capitales
los establecimientos de primer nivel
vacunarán en horario extendido
en economía
de manera inmediata para crear un millón
de empleos en un año
nuestro gobierno implementará las
siguientes medidas
golpe de inversión pública y generación
de empleo temporal activar programas
públicos de generación de empleo que a
la vez permitirán darle mantenimiento o
construir obras en todo el país
para ello se asignará
3000 millones de soles para las
municipalidades y los gobiernos
regionales para la aceleración de
inversiones mil millones de soles para
arreglar trochas carrozables a los
centros poblados del país
[Aplausos]
700 millones de soles para el programa
trabaja perú que pequeñas obras
municipales intensivas de pequeñas obras
municipales intensivas en empleo
transferencia directa e inmediata de
apoyo financiero de 700 soles a cada
familia vulnerable dado
dado que la pandemia ha generado muchos
costos en educación y salud a las
familias y a ellos
ahora se ha sumado en el último mes del
gobierno anterior una alza de precios
qué afecta a la alimentación familiar
los programas de facilidades
de crédito realizado de manera concepto
concertada entre el gobierno y el bcr
han permitido sostener a sectores
empresariales durante la pandemia pero
excluyeron a las mayorías al agro las
pymes y los consumidores por ello
queremos sostenerlos y ampliarlos
en este sentido ampliaremos los periodos
de gracia y facilitaremos la
reprogramación de deudas de las mipes
lanzaremos su nuevo programa de créditos
orientado específicamente a la
protección del empleo
y le daremos especial atención y
prioridad a los sectores más afectados
por la pandemia el agro
mip es turismo y transporte
en educación
hemos después tomar de una vez como está
en el sistema educativo en mi gobierno
será una prioridad
que este gobierno del pueblo y para el
pueblo declararemos de inmediato la
educación pública en estado de
emergencia
[Aplausos]
para recuperar los aprendizajes y evitar
que la falta de equidad siga creciendo
esto nos lleva a plantear un conjunto de
medidas que paso a detallar un
presupuesto suficiente para la educación
pública básica y superior que se
mejorará progresivamente nos prometemos
aumentar nos proponemos aumentar el
presupuesto del sector educación para
dar respuesta a las grandes necesidades
educativas de los sectores vulnerables
rurales bilingües
periferias marginales y urbanos nos
proponemos duplicar la asignación
presupuestal para la educación pública
en los primeros años de nuestro gobierno
y aumentar la participación del gasto en
el pp y mejoraremos la distribución de
los recursos educativos con criterios de
equidad y priorizando acciones que
ayuden a superar las brechas sociales
profundizadas por la pandemia se
fortalecerá la atención educativa de la
primera infancia retornando el programa
con a más a más tardar en el primer
semestre del año 2022 nuestras escuelas
volverán a la actividad presencial para
ello garantizaremos la vacunación de
todos los maestros promotores auxiliares
y personal de los servicios educativos
la adopción de medidas de bioseguridad
en todas las instituciones y programas
educativos
promoveremos la revaloración
revalorización de la carrera docente
garantizando la formación inicial y
continua de calidad y pertinente con los
entornos socio culturales el
reconocimiento y valoración del rol de
los docentes directivos de las
instituciones públicas estableciendo
estímulos que garanticen una educación
de calidad para todos consideramos de
vital importancia el sistema educativo
cuente con una base firme de profesores
estables
promoveremos en las zonas rurales
y centros de recursos pedagógicos para
los docentes es tiempo que esta vieja
aspiración se concrete y los profesores
rurales verdaderos apóstoles de la
educación peruana reciban un mínimo de
servicios para poder realizar su tan
esforzado como importante trabajo
[Aplausos]
garantizaremos el mejoramiento de los
aprendizajes de los niños y jóvenes
reduciendo las brechas históricas a
través del fortalecimiento la educación
destinada a la primera infancia junto a
las familias y comunidades el impulso
del mejoramiento del desempeño de
docentes garantizar que el currículo
nacional y los planes curriculares serán
promovidos por los propio maestro la
comunidad los estudiantes los padres de
familia y las autoridades
la innovación será una prioridad en las
escuelas y la conectividad a internet en
nuestro gobierno el internet será un
derecho no un servicio
[Aplausos]
inicialmente trabajaremos en 800
instituciones educativas habilitadas
para la educación técnica la secundaria
técnica en la escuela garantizaremos la
alimentación en los niveles inicial
primaria y secundaria
[Aplausos]
priorizaremos la preparación de
alimentos con productos locales
nutritivos de tal manera
[Aplausos]
de tal manera que al mismo tiempo se
insertarán recursos económicos para
fortalecer y desarrollar la agricultura
local
impulsaremos gradualmente una política
de ingreso libre a las universidades de
educación superior
[Aplausos]
este sistema funciona bien en otros
países y consideramos que aquí pasará lo
mismo se impulsará fuertemente las
escuelas e institutos superiores de
educación técnica y en las instituciones
educativas de educación básica también
la formación técnica en los estudiantes
en los últimos tres años de la educación
secundaria
destinaremos mil millones de soles para
pagar la deuda social del magisterio
peruano
[Aplausos]
minería
poner orden en la minería esto significa
reglas claras escenario sin sorpresas
para los actores utilizando las buenas
prácticas que se dan en otros escenarios
expulsando a la corrupción sincerando y
acortando procedimientos que faciliten
la exploración la explotación el control
y el cierre de cada adecuado de cada
proyecto haremos lo posible para reducir
para producir más y con mayor valor
agregado vivienda construcción y
saneamiento
en nuestro perú del bicentenario existen
3 millones de peruanos que no gozan de
agua potable y 17 millones y medio de
alcantarillado la cobertura de agua en
el ámbito urbano alcanza el 95 por
ciento de peruanos mientras que en el
ámbito rural sólo el 78 por ciento el
alcantarillado todavía es más
preocupante mientras en el ámbito urbano
el 89% tiene acceso a servicios de
saneamiento en el ámbito rural alcanza
sólo al 30%
la brecha de infraestructura de agua y
saneamiento es de 49 mil millones de
soles nuestro compromiso de gobierno con
el pueblo con el perú es cerrar la
brecha de servicios de agua y
saneamiento al 100% para ello
necesitamos un cambio total en la forma
de servir al estado en los 100 primeros
días de nuestro gobierno se fortalecerá
la ejecución de obras de saneamiento
rural sostenibles y de calidad a través
de los núcleos ejecutores
como un mecanismo para promover la
participación directa y vigilante de la
sociedad civil organizada y al mismo
tiempo combatir el cáncer de la
corrupción
[Aplausos]
se facilitará a la población el es el
acceso al programa nacional pecho propio
y ampliaremos significativamente el
número de beneficiarios la esperanza de
cientos de miles de familias para
acceder a un techo propio a partir de
hoy empieza a hacerse realidad además
promoveremos la formalización de predios
rurales y urbanos a través de un trabajo
conjunto con los gobiernos locales para
ello si se simplificará la normativa
sobre titulación de predios y se
firmarán convenios interinstitucionales
para realizar el levantamiento catastral
urbano en menos tiempo
[Aplausos]
producciones
promoveremos y reconoceremos a las
industrias e inversiones que tengan
rentabilidad social con políticas
específicas para la gran empresa para
los pequeños negocios y para los
sectores comunales y cooperativos
revisaremos las condiciones económicas
con grandes empresas pesqueras para la
obtención de mayores ingresos
tributarios para el país y para que
genere mayor valor agregado e
industrialización de nuestros recursos
naturales y marinos y marinos y empleo
digno aseguraremos la sostenibilidad en
la en la explotación de recursos
pesqueros y la cadena productiva para el
consumo humano directo en base al
ordenamiento y fiscalización en la
captura de especies marinas realizadas
por las grandes y medianas empresas la
investigación para la sostenibilidad y
la ampliación y diversificación de pesca
para el consumo y la acuicultura
promoveremos la micro y pequeña empresa
de acuicultura y la implementación de
parques industriales acuícolas
la producción de anchoveta en salazón
charqui y embutidos con los pescadores
artesanales y el reflote de una nueva de
nuestra industria para abastecer a
nuestros programas de asistencia
alimentaria
[Aplausos]
para las finas e incrementaremos fondos
de crédito con tasas preferenciales a
través de las cajas rurales y cajas
municipales y banca privada y el banco
de la nación con tope diferenciado según
el requerimiento de cada rubro y sector
flexibilizar hemos los requisitos para
facilitar el acceso a créditos y
formalización de las mipes el estado
evaluará las mipes para que accedan a
préstamos y se rectifiquen reconociendo
el prestigio de ellas como buenos
pagadores se desarrollarán alianzas
estratégicas para el desarrollo
tecnológico y productivo entre la
universidad y la educación técnica en
todos los niveles
agricultura y desarrollo rural
hambre y desnutrición cero con salud y
reactivación económica promoviendo el
consumo de productos sanos ecológicos
para ello impulsaremos los programas de
compras estatales con productos locales
nutritivos y de calidad para combatir en
una manera inmediata el hambre en las
zonas rurales y urbanas las
organizaciones sociales de ollas comunes
y comedores populares serán reconocidas
e integradas a este ambicioso programa
nacional
para la inmediata reactivación económica
del sector rural
destinaremos tres mil millones de soles
para el fondo maya agro haciendo más
accesible y con mayor presencia a nivel
nacional el agrobanco se convertirá en
un eficiente motor del desarrollo de la
agricultura del país
de manera especial
del pequeño productor agropecuario y aún
de la agricultura familiar hoy menos del
2.5 por ciento del total de agricultores
califica para acceder a los créditos de
esa entidad y eso no puede continuar
implementaremos el plan nacional de
industrialización y mejora productiva
desde el campo con la participación de
los gobiernos regionales y los gobiernos
locales dirección haremos fondos
públicos para darles equipos y
tecnología de punta a los agricultores
organizados
[Aplausos]
la inmediata puesta en marcha del plan
nacional de repoblamiento ganadero que
volverá que devolverá productividad a
más de un millón
además de 1.7 millones de familias
ganaderas en la costa en la sierra y en
la selva el mejor modo de combatir la
anemia será permitiendo que nuestros
hijos coman proteínas de gran calidad y
ricas en hierro priorizar los proyectos
de irrigación
así mismo proyecto de siembra y cosecha
de agua para integrarnos a los mercados
internacionales aprovecharemos nuestra
biodiversidad para el desarrollo
productivo agro agrario industrial
[Aplausos]
mujer y poblaciones vulnerables programa
nacional mujer emprendedora que otorga
créditos accesibles para dinamizar la
economía familiar para enfrentar las
consecuencias económicas de la pandemia
que ha ubicado a las mujeres en empleos
informales vulnerables y sin protección
social
[Aplausos]
e impulsar el sistema nacional de
cuidado de personas dependientes niñas
niños personas adultas mayores personas
con discapacidad dado que 98 mil niños
peruanos han perdido a uno de sus de uno
de sus cuidadores como víctimas de la
pandemia en adelante por los niños y
niñas del perú el estado asumirá el
financiamiento de la rehabilitación
integral de las víctimas de violencia
sexual
[Aplausos]
fortaleceremos el sistema nacional
especializado de justicia para la
protección y sanción de la violencia
contra las mujeres e integrantes del
grupo familiar solo de forma articulada
y coordinada se logrará la protección y
acceso real a la justicia para las
víctimas ministerio de ciencia y
tecnología y la carrera del investigador
científico
por nuestro bajo nivel en ciencia
tecnología e innovación
las exportaciones correspondientes al
año 2019 estuvieron compuestas por 79%
de productos sin valor agregado este
porcentaje subió del 81% el año 2020 por
la globalización y el calentamiento
global se prevé que esta realidad se
agravará
para hacer frente a estos desafíos mi
gobierno promoverá la creación del
ministerio de ciencia tecnología e
innovación tecnológica
[Aplausos]
con este ministerio se potenciará la
generación de conocimiento necesario
para el desarrollo y la independencia
tecnológica del perú asimismo será
necesario estudiar la posibilidad de una
carrera del investigador científico y
tecnológico para incorporar a los
talentos egresados
y repatriar a los que emigraron por
falta de oportunidades la ciencia y la
tecnología son los pilares del
desarrollo contemporáneo un país que no
es capaz de reconocer e incorporar sus
conocimientos ancestrales y generar
nuevos a partir de la investigación y
disponer y promover un universo de
profesionales destacados en este campo
nunca podrá alcanzar los niveles de
desarrollo requeridos para distribuir
adecuadamente entre su población los
servicios públicos elementales como son
la seguridad alimentaria la vivienda
adecuada el transporte público eficiente
y una educación y un sistema de salud
pública pertinente y de calidad
[Aplausos]
petro perú petroperú significa participe
y participará en todos los aspectos de
la industria petrolera la explotación y
explotación de los exploración y
explotación de los yacimientos de
petróleo y gas natural el transporte
hacia las refinerías y la
comercialización de los derivados así
podremos regular los precios finales y
evitar que se explote al ciudadano se
eleve en los precios de los alimentos y
los pasajes para beneficio de unas
empresas de una empresa monopólica no
estamos hablando de subsidios públicos
pues esta empresa deberá participar
plenamente en el mercado con sus
recursos propios pero con una tasa de
ganancia razonable y sin ningún tipo de
abuso
[Aplausos]
estamos dispuestos a recuperar la
soberanía sobre todos nuestros recursos
naturales porque muchos hoy en día están
en manos extranjeras con contratos que
tienen garantía de estabilidad
tributaria esa es una de las razones
principales que nos obligan a buscar una
nueva constitución política que entre
otras cosas permita adecuar los
contratos
[Aplausos]
a las cambiantes circunstancias del
mercado internacional
garantizando los ingresos del estado
las rondas y la seguridad ciudadana
sabemos que la seguridad ciudadana es
uno de los problemas más sentidos por la
población la policía nacional es el
pilar sobre el cual la actividad pública
lucha contra este mal pero eso no es
suficiente a pesar de los esfuerzos que
se realizan en este campo siguen
campeando las pandillas las bandas y los
robos callejeros las agresiones a la
integridad física de las personas y a
sus vidas nosotros creemos que debemos
expandir el sistema de las rondas en el
perú que no es otra cosa que la
población organizada para dar seguridad
a toda la población la imagen de las
rondas campesinas nos proponemos
convocar a toda la población a conformar
las donde no existe
estás
e incluirlas en el sistema nacional de
seguridad ciudadana en los niveles
regionales y locales correspondientes
[Aplausos]
asignaremos un presupuesto para dotarlos
de logística necesaria a sí mismo
promoveremos su participación en la
fiscalización a las autoridades en la
ejecución de la inversión pública en las
comunidades
fortaleceremos
la ley de rondas y sirviendo en su
organización interna respetando su
autonomía estamos seguros que
conjuntamente con la policía nacional
del perú podremos acceder a una más
eficiente seguridad pública los
delincuentes extranjeros tendrán 72
horas de plazo a partir de la fecha para
salir del país
[Aplausos]
finalmente los jóvenes que no estudian
ni trabajan deberán acudir al servicio
militar
defensa
para las fuerzas armadas ciertamente
nuestras fuerzas armadas tienen como se
establece el artículo 165 de la
constitución la finalidad primordial de
garantizar la independencia la soberanía
y la integridad territorial de la
república sin embargo
en tiempo de en tiempo de paz nada
impide que los equipos el personal
técnico y en general todo el personal
disponible pueda participar en la
ejecución de proyectos de desarrollo
como caminos obras de ingeniería
represas
consideramos que esto no es sólo posible
sino necesario
esta función está normal en el artículo
171 de la constitución pero se ha
restringido por razones políticas
volveremos a encargar a las fuerzas
armadas la participación de algunos
importantes proyectos de desarrollo este
será uno de los cambios que impulsaremos
desde el pri del poder ejecutivo
reforzaremos la institucionalidad de las
fuerzas armadas teniendo presente la
meritocracia antes que el amiguismo para
los ascensos
pedro castillo es el presidente del
bicentenario de perú y está ya en pleno
ejercicio de sus funciones un líder
campesino o maestro y rostro de una
izquierda particular que con biblia en
mano avanzó hasta la silla presidencial
pero polémico porque viene de un partido
perú libre ya marcado por la corrupción
y por su idea de la llamada economía
popular de mercado que esperaba saque al
país de la crisis cuando esa penosamente
líder de la tasa de mortalidad por kobe
19 ha dicho castillo que el suyo es un
gobierno del pueblo por el pueblo y para
el pueblo en cabeza de un campesino y
miembro de los sectores oprimidos en sus
líneas políticas habló de la lucha
contra kobe 19 y de los esfuerzos para
vacunar a toda la población en el menor
tiempo posible hablo de un sistema de
salud universal y descentralizado y de
fortalecer la atención primaria también
de la reactivación económica centrándose
en las fallas del modelo económico
implementado en los 90 y dijo que la
pandemia precisamente visibilizó todas
esas debilidades además de pedro
castillo habla
de preservar la cultura y el medio
ambiente con un control de la minería y
que si un proyecto no tiene rentabilidad
social simplemente no va en educación
hablo de que será prioridad del gobierno
la educación pública que se declarará en
estado de emergencia para evitar que la
falta de equidad siga creciendo y
aumentar el presupuesto para dar
prioridad a los sectores vulnerables de
la población prometió que en sus
primeros 100 días se fortalecerán las
obras de saneamiento para aumentar el
acceso a zonas rurales que solamente
tienen 30 por ciento de accesibilidad
todo esto deberá lograrlo con un
congreso en oposición y es que
precisamente la fractura en el
legislativo se demuestra en la
distribución de los 130 congresistas que
han tomado asiento hasta 2026 con un
total de 10 partidos políticos con
representación pero libre partido del
presidente castillo es el que más
escaños tiene con 37 sin embargo son
insuficientes para lograr mayorías vamos
a las imágenes de hecho el partido
fuerza popular de keiko fujimori
contaría ya con un bloque de 64 escaños
acto con alianza para el progreso avanza
país renovación popular y podemos perú
que podría verse aumentada a un total de
80 si logran el apoyo de acción popular
por lo que tendrían mayoría en el
congreso y así la posibilidad de
bloquear en la gestión de castillo
vamos sin más demora a nuestro análisis
con nuestro invitado de hoy nuestro
analista en su ceguera quien nos
acompaña desde perú eso bienvenido a
france 24 y el parlamento que hoy le
toma juramento como presidente a
castillo que le tomó juramento está en
manos evidentemente de la oposición la
derecha lo controla como mantendrá la
gobernabilidad de su partido pero libre
solamente tiene 37 puestos de 130 que
conforman el parlamento
una situación bastante compleja porque
nos evidencia que vamos a tener a un
parlamento que además viene como
institución de experiencias saboteadoras
a otros presidentes a otros antecesores
de hecho el parlamento ha colocado por
lo menos a dos presidentes en el último
quinquenio haciendo una un
enfrentamiento entre el legislativo y el
ejecutivo de manera constante una
negociación que muchas veces no ha
tenido los mejores fines y que se han
nombrado en muchas negociaciones bajo la
mesa con la finalidad no solamente de
colocar a un presidente de la república
sino sabotear de manera sistemática va a
ser muy compleja esta situación sin
embargo en base a la negociación y al
diálogo se podría evitar que tengan una
mayoría más absoluta de las fuerzas de
oposición pero de lo que sí sabemos que
puede hacer mano el presidente castillo
es con la movilización
en la víspera de las elecciones y ante
muchas situaciones en que se ponían en
tela de juicio está contabilidad de
votos ellos no han tenido problemas de
movilizar a la población en general y
creo que va a utilizar mucho de esto y
si es necesario va a recurrir a
referentes o consultas populares con la
finalidad de darle viabilidad en caso
como siempre y como hay previsión aunque
el parlamento juegue este error
obstruccionista
muchas gracias censo y regreso también
con nuestro corresponsal francisco
zacarías francisco usted ha cubierto la
realidad política del país desde hace
cuatro años con france24 castillo ha
dicho que es necesario que el estado
intervenga más en la economía porque
para él el libre mercado lo único que ha
hecho es aumentar las desigualdades y
con eso en mente para usted cuál es cómo
ve los lineamientos del gobierno que
viene en un contexto de suma
polarización
bueno contar de liliana que es
precisamente lo que han venido
reclamando la población rural del
interior del país y también la mayoría
de ciudadanos que haya una protección
por parte del estado a lo que es la
producción la venta de productos la
economía donde la constitución de 1993
diversos observadores sociales han dicho
que ha estado privilegiando a grupos de
poder a empresarios en diversos sectores
del país y estos diversos observadores
sociales han dicho que ha ido en
desmedro de lo que es en los bolsillos
de los ciudadanos del peruano de a pie
mejor dicho entonces pedro castillo
trata de recuperar los derechos de la
ciudadanía de la población recordemos
que él es un maestro rural bien
justamente la población al interior del
país donde no hay carreteras no existen
servicios de salud donde tienen mayores
problemas entonces
él está tratando de corregir lo que a su
juicio denomina una injusticia es por
eso que también él ha propuesto la
recuperación de los recursos naturales y
también lo que se denomina la
explotación de los recursos de un link
de dineros energéticos petroleros que va
a necesitar una supervisión y mayor
participación del estado castillo ha
dicho que ahora va a tener que ser un
estado
socio de la empresa privada donde en el
estado peruano va a tener que tener
mayor presencia y participación y toda
la producción que propició la riqueza
que se genere va a tener que beneficiar
a la población local y regional es
justamente eso ha sido lo que él ha
esbozado como una de las principales
razones para modificar la constitución
peruana
esto no ha sido del agrado de la mayoría
de los congresistas porque solamente un
sector de los legisladores aplaudió
cuando era acaba de hacer estos anuncios
otro anuncio importante que ha hecho
pero casi va en el tema de la educación
es que se va a establecer el ingreso
directo a las universidades y ha sido
muy criticado en este país que los
estudiantes quienes han venido
recibiendo una ayuda de una educación no
del todo 100% perfecta han tenido que
pasar por rigurosos exámenes de admisión
de las universidades y precisamente son
las universidades particulares la que
más han lucrado con estos exámenes de
admisión que también ha sido duramente
criticado desde hace mucho tiempo por
colectivos que ven los derechos de los
ciudadanos entonces él va a permitir que
los
estudiantes que egresen de la secundaria
tengan un ingreso directo a los centros
de educación superior y también ha
señalado que aquellos jóvenes que no
estudian ni trabajan- pasen a formar
parte del servicio militar obligatorio
esto es en mayor medida los primeros
lineamientos de lo que va a ser este su
siguiente
el gobierno que va a ser de cinco años
que se inicia el día de hoy y va a
tratar de tender puentes con los
partidos políticos que los puedan ayudar
a gobernar
lógicamente acá va a tener una situación
muy dura porque la mayoría del congreso
está siendo controlado por la derecha
hay una coalición de partidos políticos
que son muy cercanos ideales a keiko
fujimori desde ya ellos han adelantado
que no van a tratar de darle pase con
las reformas y diversos analistas han
venido señalando que pedro castillo al
tener una bancada de 37 congresistas es
vulnerable a cualquier tipo de boicot o
bloqueo por parte de las otras bancadas
que en su mayoría tienen el control del
parlamento de gente hay otra situación
también que pedro casi va a tener que
hilar fino porque él
digamos cumplir con las promesas que
hizo en campaña en las elecciones de
este año y que fueron apoyadas por mayor
medida por un 50 o mejor dicho una parte
de la población quien tiene que
responder a esos electores que lo han
llevado a la presidencia del perú pero
si él trata de cumplir los lineamientos
del partido perú libre que lo llevó al
poder y dice en diversos analistas que
va a ser muy difícil para que hay una
gobernabilidad estable esto puede
generar nuevos enfrentamientos lo que
hemos visto en anteriores situaciones
tanto con pedro pablo kuczynski y martín
vizcarra
gracias a usted zacarías y en su regreso
con usted la estrategia del fujimorismo
dilató un mes y medio los resultados
argumentando fraude electoral en que
quedan ahora las denuncias de keiko
fujimori y además el proceso judicial
que tiene pendiente por corrupción cómo
afectará esto el gobierno de pedro
castillo
bueno en principio todas las acciones
legales que haya emprendido contra los
organismos electorales quedan siendo
obsoletas porque ninguna institución del
estado cede el poder judicial sea el
tribunal constitucional o cualquiera
otra puede interferir sobre el proceso
de contabilidad que ha tenido el jurado
nacional de elecciones porque es un ente
autónomo es decir sobre él no hay
ninguna institución que le ordene o le
diga que hacer o incluso interpretar
algún tipo de normas en favor o en
contra de la institucionalidad en
segundo lugar si están extensos los
juicios que tiene que enfrentar keiko
fujimori
muchos analistas coincidíamos en que el
tener la presidencia le iba a poder
tener un ángulo mayor de manipulación
por encima de su proceso sin embargo se
acerca una gran cantidad no solamente
del proceso de ella misma sino de muchos
aliados que durante la campaña y
difamaron
incluso hubieron programas de medios de
comunicación en donde sin mayor prueba
alguna o manipulando pruebas acusaron al
entonces candidato pedro castillo de
tener alianzas incluso con el terrorismo
o lo tildaron solo adjetivizar o de
muchas formas entonces se prevee que va
a ser un enfrentamiento a nivel judicial
por todas estas responsabilidades en el
marco de keiko fujimori es sobre la
investigación del lavado de activos y
otras va a continuar su normal
desarrollo y se está observando por
ejemplo como parte del proceso que ella
en la campaña electoral se habría
comunicado con implicados en las
investigaciones incluso habría
despachado desde la casa de uno de los
implicados o investigados y esta era
evidentemente una de las prohibiciones
que tiene cualquier persona
a estar siguiendo su proceso y tiene
digamos el permiso de seguir con ciertas
condiciones o lo que se denominan la
libertad condicional que su estatus
actual le queda enfrentar aunque
paralelamente va a tratar de
victimizarse como lo ha hecho en
anteriores oportunidades en relación a
que esto puede ser consecuencia del
enfrentamiento que ya tuvo y que
sostenemos que va a continuar contra
pedro castillo entonces esta situación
es completamente compleja para ella como
persona y como candidata pero sabemos
por la conducta que ha tenido como
política que va a continuar con estas
marchas que iba a tratar de capitalizar
lo mejor posible recordemos que en el
tiempo de pedro pablo kuczynski y
también ejerció una gran presión y lo
hizo o lo obligó incluso a negociar con
él tan es así que parte del entorno
fujimori estuvo en puestos claves
estuvieron en el banco central de
reservas y estuvieron incluso dirigiendo
la zona que es la entidad que además
tiene una relevancia para detectar temas
como de lavado de activos entre otras
prerrogativas sin embargo eso no fue
suficiente para terminar amenazando al
presidente y obligándolo a renunciar
ante la falta de votos en el parlamento
mira fueron cinco presidentes en cinco
años entonces estamos hablando de
kuczynski de vizcarra de merino de
sagasti ahora llega el pedro castillo y
esto es en parte por un caso fuertísimo
de corrupción o por una crisis política
que aún no sabemos si se va a poder
resolver pero con un congreso en contra
de gran mayoría de derecha esto podría
significar que peligra la estancia de
pedro castillo en la presidencia
sí por supuesto de hecho fuera de la
tradición parlamentaria del último
quinquenio de haber producido cambios
definitivamente irresponsables en mucho
porque no se dio tiempo siquiera que las
investigaciones se desarrollaran para
aclarar que parte de las acusaciones
eran ciertas o no existe un capítulo en
la constitución de la república que
justo ente apela a la moralidad y
evidentemente la incapacidad moral que
así lo denomina es un término subjetivo
no está ni interpretado ni reglamentado
y el congreso podría acusar de
inmoralidad por ejemplo en que el
presidente se reúna con alguien por
ejemplo cuestionable y simplemente por
ese tipo de hechos el parlamento de
manera antojadiza podría acomodar en
algunas piezas para poder enfrentarse al
presidente e intentar reemplazarlo o por
lo menos y bajarlo sin embargo sí
eso ocurriese está la primera
vicepresidenta no que evidentemente es
una persona que pertenece al partido
perú libre y así ellos tendrían que
analizar qué tanto les va a convenir que
quizás entre alguien de una izquierda
aún mucho más extrema entonces habrán
evaluaciones y sorpresas que tendrían
que hacer recién cuando sí bajarán a
esta primera y única vicepresidenta
porque no hay dos vicepresidentes como
normalmente se presentan en las
elecciones peruanas así recién podría en
la cabeza de la mesa directiva del
congreso es ser además presidente de la
república en esa hipotética situación
evidentemente es muy peligroso ya ha
ocurrido y teniendo está esta nueva
mayoría podrían realizarlo y podrían
amenazar incluso al presidente ante
determinadas acciones que ellos no
consideran como por ejemplo el cambio de
rumbo
de la constitución entonces hay que allí
no solamente habrá que hilar sino tener
un poder de negociación y un poder sobre
todo popular en donde reiteró va a
acudir a la ciudadanía en más de una
oportunidad para tratar de defenderse
del parlamento y yo no podría decir que
esta vez los enfrentamientos van a
seguir las mismas suertes de los
anteriores presidentes porque podría
evidentemente también el presidente
utilizar mecanismos para terminar el
periodo del congreso por ejemplo ante
alguna cuestión de confianza dos veces
reiterativas que en su momento utilizó
martín vizcarra para cerrar el
parlamento entonces va a haber un juego
de poder bastante interesante pero que
puede terminar siendo dañino para la
democracia y para quienes el pueblo
finalmente en mayoría dio y eligió a un
presidente
eso ya regreso con usted vamos a seguir
escuchando el discurso de pedro castillo
que continúa hablándole a la nación
que la agobian convoco a todos los
peruanos
a los hombres y mujeres de esta patria
sin distingos de ninguna naturaleza para
decirles que ahora es el tiempo de la
reconstrucción de la gran unidad
nacional esta es una tarea que nos
compromete a todos no haremos en
democracia buscándola lo haremos en
democracia buscando la concertación
nacional asegurando una vez más que el
28 de julio del 2026 regresaré a mis
labores docentes de siempre como decía
nuestros antepasados quechuas antes de
emprender una gran tarea putumayo
puig un kia y good maquilla una sola
fuerza un solo corazón una sola
dirección
[Aplausos]
y que la dirección del progreso y la
justicia social para todos los peruanos
muchas gracias pueblo peruano viva el
perú
viva la patria
ah
[Aplausos]
continuamos con este especial
informativo transmitiendo la transición
desde el poder ahora pedro castillo es
el nuevo presidente de perú el
representante de perú libre un maestro
de izquierda que llega por primera vez a
la silla presidencial en ese país
latinoamericano regresamos con el
análisis en so esta es una posesión
presidencial con una gran carga
simbólica es el bicentenario del perú el
cierre de una crisis política muy fuerte
en la que cinco presidentes desfilaron
por el palacio presidencial la casa de
pizarro en cinco años con renuncias con
destituciones y con corrupción en el
prontuario que debe hacer castillo para
ganarse la confianza de los peruanos con
50 como 12 por ciento de apoyos en las
elecciones evidentemente están muy lejos
de unificar el país
bueno lo primero que le toca hacer a
pedro castillo es no solamente
concentrarse en los programas de
gobierno que ha anunciado sino de manera
ejemplar tratar de apagar todos los
temores que se habían centrado en torno
a él y que habían manipulado a la otra
gran parte de la población para que
votar en contra de él por ejemplo uno de
ellos es tener mano firme contra el
terrorismo y además ser muy duro en
cuanto a todas las prácticas subversivas
que puedan haber en segundo lugar y
deslindar en la práctica a través de
reuniones con los grupos empresariales
he dicho ya sostuvo una de ellas a antes
de ser proclamado presidente y con la
finalidad de generar también confianza y
estabilidad no solamente el empresariado
sino de los mercados financieros lo ha
dicho en su discurso pero es
momento de que haga acciones y gestos
que empiecen a garantizar dicha
estabilidad y con ello también disminuir
la volatilidad del dólar frente al sol
peruano nuestra moneda nacional entonces
esas primeras acciones y esas primeras
muestras lo que van a hacer es que pueda
bajar la movilidad o la la capacidad de
movilización popular que pueda tener la
extrema derecha y mostrarse pues
relacionado en que quiere trabajar con
el empresariado pero también con la
población por supuesto para tampoco
defraudar a los votantes entonces que
estas primeras acciones van a ser
saludables y van a poder desinflar no
solamente los fantasmas sino también
aquellas expresiones infra ternas que se
han vertido contra él a lo largo de toda
la campaña electoral creo que las
muestras los ejemplos la imagen que
habla es por más de mil palabras
muy necesarias en estos primeros días de
gobierno
y de los cuales normalmente se le suele
dar tres meses de gracia a los
presidentes pero considero que no la va
a tener porque él también va a tomar
puntos medulares en estos días en estos
primeros días de gobierno y obviamente
no todos van a estar contentos
francisco zacarías anunció pedro
castillo durante su discurso una
asamblea constituyente y que tampoco
gobernará desde el palacio de gobierno
ya antes había dicho que tampoco iba a
cobrar el sueldo presidencial entonces
por favor amplíe nos sobre esta noticia
así pues es un anuncio que ha causado
sorpresa especialmente a la delegación
del rey de españa felipe sexto pedro
castillo ha dicho que él va a romper la
tradición que ha tenido siempre en cada
gobierno del perú que la residencia del
presidente del país es el palacio de
gobierno
comúnmente conocido como el palacio de
pizarro pedro castillo ha dicho que va a
romper con todo colonialismo o digamos
mejor aún que tengan vínculos con el
colonialismo y va a gobernar el desde
otro lado que no va a ser el palacio de
gobierno todavía no se ha dado a conocer
cuál va a ser la residencia del gobierno
de este nuevo presidente pero ha dicho
que el palacio de gobierno se va a
dedicar a un museo va a ser un museo
donde se va a mostrar o revalorizar las
culturas pedro castillo es un indígena
viene de la región de cajamarca y él
como maestro de escuela siempre ha
tratado de revalorizar la cultura
[Música]
nos estamos quedando sin audio francisco
ya regreso con ustedes tan pronto
podamos solucionar los problemas de
sonido mientras continuamos con la
transmisión en directo después desde la
salida del congreso del ahora presidente
del perú pedro castillo quien ha hecho
promesas muy ambiciosas una de ellas es
el cambio de la constitución una de sus
promesas bandera fue la de hacer un
referendo que permita llegar a este
cambio que tan factible sería cumplir
esa promesa y que tanto necesita perú
reformar su carta magna ya sabemos que
esa idea no le cayó bien al congreso en
general en su
si definitivamente la movilización que
esto va a generar va a ser inmensa para
muchos está esta medida no debió tomarse
de manera tan inmediata sino debió
concentrarse en la unión de todos los
peruanos sin embargo en la medida en que
él explique cuáles son los cambios y
cuáles son las garantías
constitucionales que por ejemplo se van
a mantener y se van a respetar los
contratos con los privados los los
derechos fundamentales que se adquieren
en relación a todo el respeto y la
legalidad de los tratos antes firmados
con la empresa con la inversión
especialmente también con la minería le
va a dar una garantía de que estos
cambios finalmente pueden ser para
mejorar aspectos económicos pero también
para garantizar la distribución de la
riqueza que justamente es el punto
medular de la ciudadanía recordemos
además que si bien es cierto
ha tenido el poder desestabilizador
frente al ejecutivo en el último
quinquenio también ha tenido la mayor
parte de impopularidad y que ha podido
tener los parlamentos entonces esto
puede hacer que vía referéndum por
ejemplo se corte algún periodo del
parlamento o pueda hacerse tomar otro
tipo de medidas más estrictas porque
incluso con referéndum antes dados en el
gobierno por ejemplo de vizcarra el
parlamento trató de aprobar parcialmente
estas medidas y otras no haciendo caso
omiso a lo que se había planteado como
referéndum entonces siempre el
parlamento va a tener un ángulo de
manipulación y castillo va a tener que
hacerse sentir como reiteró en las
calles a través de las consultas
populares y además de diego lo que hace
minutos también nos digo disculpe que lo
interrumpa la noticia de que él dijo que
iba a convocar una constituyente que iba
a pasar el proyecto entonces esto podría
cambiar
ampliamente las normas del juego de aquí
en adelante
sí por supuesto podría por ejemplo
retirarse esa parte de la norma en donde
dice que el gobierno puede ser
destituido por incapacidad moral para
gobernar y se podría reglamentar cuáles
son específicamente los casos o podría
ser retirado entonces esta situación por
ejemplo no no le caería nada nada bien
al parlamento porque le quitaría el arma
o la lanza que suele utilizar frente al
ejecutivo
evidentemente hay algunos temas de la
norma constitucional que podrían ser
modificados o retirados y esto le
jugaría o le restaría poder al
parlamento a que el poder no
fiscalizador sino obstruccionista y de
enfrentamiento y que le da la capacidad
además de poder colocar a un nuevo
presidente de la república en caso de
que se termine
con el presidente y vicepresidente así
que en este caso incluso sobre una
vicepresidenta entonces esto podría
deben estar en mucho y obviamente hay
muchos intereses creados para que
tampoco se muevan las normas del juego
actual sin embargo la mayoría de
peruanos finalmente que puede ser
incluso por un voto hacer la mayoría ha
votado por un cambio en las reglas del
juego y habrá que hacer más evaluaciones
sociales pero las últimas que se
realizaron en evidencia del cambio de
constitución en su mayoría la aprobaba
por que la consideraban injusta
socialmente y que obviamente con el
devenir de la pandemia había agudizado
aquellas diferencias imágenes en directo
transmitidas por france24 después de la
posición presidencial de pedro castillo
ya está con nosotros nuevamente de
francisco zacarías nuestro corresponsal
en lima y le pregunto francisco qué se
sabe de este anuncio de llevaron la
constituyente adelante
justamente retomamos la información el
pedro caceo ha dicho que va a modificar
la constitución de 1993 esta
constitución fue aprobada durante el
primer gobierno del ex presidente
alberto fujimori entonces el castillo
hecho una reflexión al interior del
parlamento peruano como es así que una
constitución donde la mayoría de los
peruanos que en aquella época no vivían
o mejor dicho ni siquiera nacía y hoy
tienen alrededor de 40 años o más tengan
que seguirla cuando no todos ellos están
de acuerdo con una constitución que
señala casi o protege intereses
particulares entonces él ha planteado en
este primer mensaje a los peruanos de
modificar la carta magna para ello ha
presentado o ha dicho que va a presentar
un proyecto de ley para convocar a una
asamblea constituyente y ha señalado que
esperando que después de presentar su
proyecto el cual se ha estudiado
debatido
y desarrollado por los congresistas
pedro castillo espera que sea aprobada
seguidamente ha dicho que se va a
convocar a una asamblea constituyente
que adelantado que estará conformada por
ciudadanos pluricultural es el ha
llamado a los indígenas amazónicos y a
los pueblos originarios para tratar de
que haya una representatividad ha hecho
un llamado a los peruanos para que
participen con ideas y propuestas y él
ha dicho que se va a tratar de mejorar
el sistema de gobierno y el sistema
económico precisamente eso es lo que
anunció durante minutos antes de su
disertación en el parlamento él ha dicho
que se requiere cambios y justamente él
señaló que va a tratar de que los
recursos naturales sean
explotados por las empresas pero en
estos proyectos el estado va a tener una
mayor presencia como socio estratégico y
que todo esto genere riqueza y que sea
distribuida a la población local y
regional y asimismo que el estado tenga
una mayor participación en el pago de
los tributos en estos años en perú ha
habido muchas quejas en bajo reach o
denuncias de diversos colectivos
sociales que hay empresas extranjeras
que vienen explotando en los sectores de
minería petróleo y también gas natural y
que además de no tener cuidado con el
medio ambiente ni con las comunidades
vecinas estos proyectos
estas empresas no pagaban impuestos y
deberían al erario nacional millones de
dólares pues bien pedro castillo ha
querido poner la casa en orden y está
emprendiendo esta nueva política de
gobierno que va a tratar de decir a las
empresas qué
si quieren operar primero necesitan un
permiso social de las comunidades donde
se ejecutan estos proyectos de inversión
y posteriormente va a entender que el
gobierno peruano a través de los
organismos reguladores tener una mayor
participación en los dividendos que
produzcan esos proyectos de energía de
desarrollo de minería y posteriormente
van a tener que ser fiscalizados por lo
que es la dirección de tributos conocida
como la ciudad
con su sombrero chotano de cajamarca el
primer presidente que no brota de la
élite podrá honrar o no su origen y
gobernar para el grueso de la población
y le preguntó en su ser a ver de verdad
este un gobierno del pueblo ya cuando
nos acercamos al final de este especial
informativo
el reto va a ser muy importante porque
se va a ver si finalmente puede mantener
su discurso o termina formando un grupo
de poder o un oligopolio que lo termine
o termine el empoderándolos para
mantener o para sostenerse en el tiempo
entonces las medidas concretas y de
hecho si tiene que rodearse o armar
grupos del poder pero el que tanto los
empodere o que tanto los reglamentos o
los privilegios por encima de otros
podría hacer que surja una una nueva
clase porque puede empoderar a personas
que no están articulados ante una actual
y digamos social económicamente más alta
y encumbrar la sería hacer más de lo
mismo entonces está este equilibrio va a
ser muy difícil pero va a ser un reto
significativo que va a tener de manera
equilibrada que manejar el poder y allí
también habría que ver el liderazgo que
voy a ejercer pedro castillo no quisiera
aventurarme a hacer predicciones no
conocemos todavía en si o formalmente
todos los ministros que de hecho van a
comentar aún el día de mañana pero eso
sí nos va a poder dar una visión a
miento de un grupo de cierta
predictibilidad en sus acciones y las
primeras acciones también van a
encaminar no se ha dirigido por ejemplo
de manera confrontación a la los medios
de comunicación a pesar de ellos en su
mayoría tuvieron una fuerte presión y
desgaste para evitar que pedro castillo
salga como presidente y eso finalmente
termina haciendo
una señal de equilibrio vamos a ver qué
tanto se mantiene es muy difícil hacerlo
no ha tenido prerrogativas en hablar del
respecto del tema delante de los
representantes de españa desde la
monarquía española entonces habrá que
ver qué tanto equilibro mantiene en las
otras situaciones que no van a ser menos
difíciles para él y dónde va a tener que
tomar decisiones importantes
pues eso ya para el cierre muy
rápidamente solo me quedan algunos
minutos que quería preguntarle por el
nombre de vladimir cerrón que de todas
maneras queda rondando en el ambiente
después de la posición de pedro castillo
fundador del partido perú libre
inhabilitado por un caso de corrupción
que tanto afectará este antecedente de
pedro castillo durante su presidencia
va a depender de lo que finalmente
termine haciendo la justicia peruana en
relación del casco de vladimir cerrón
puesto que si terminara hipotéticamente
siendo condenado obviamente cualquier
digamos acercamiento o vínculo va a ser
cuestionado por la opinión pública pero
si finalmente la justicia peruana oa
través de los mecanismos que él ha
presentado le termina favoreciendo
entonces lo que haría es fortalecer un
poco la imagen de que él ha mencionado
durante la campaña que era víctima de
una persecución política va a depender
un poco en principio de lo que mencioné
la posición pero nada cuando hasta hace
poco había sido cuestionado incluso en
campaña el pedro castillo había
mencionado lo mismo el señor vladimir
cerrón era víctima de las circunstancias
y de una persecución política e incluso
se descubrió que habían indicios
de persecución de los servicios de
inteligencia a vladimir cerrón entonces
una vez que estos hechos se aclaren creo
que él va a tener que ya tomar
decisiones sin embargo políticamente él
es el presidente del partido político
perú libre y obviamente tiene una
preponderancia una relevancia incluso se
le ha visto en reuniones formales
con él incluso es mandatarios de otros
países el mismo evo morales entonces yo
creo que la importancia se verán más
severa en el futuro rock era en estas
circunstancias muchísimas gracias a
usted agradecimiento especiales en su
helguera ceo de la encuestadora y +1 y
analista invitado de france 24 a nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
por este cubrimiento especial del cambio
de mando presidencial en perú llegamos
al final pero en minutos hoy regresamos
con más siguen france24
[Música]